so let's look at a better solution
because this should not be a problem
that every single developer of
server-side applications need to think
about
fortunately the Google cloud platform
has a product that takes care of most of
these things it's called App Engine and
that's what we will be using in this
course let's take a closer look
App Engine is a development a deployment
platform that takes care of many things
for your application for example it
performs all the scaling for you
automatically so when your application
runs on App Engine and there is more
traffic it needs to manage then App
Engine will increase the number of
instances to use to take care of the
load this is called
scaling up and at other times when your
application is not so busy App Engine
will reduce the number of instances to
save resources and cost this is called
scaling down and this scaling is done
automatically you don't need to write a
single line of application code to get
this benefit and it doesn't stop with
automatic scaling the App Engine
platform has functionality to deal with
all of the things we previously looked
at so there is no need for you to do any
design or coding to deal with that and
this is no coincidence
Google has been the leader in designing
scalable systems and all that experience
was built into App Engine when it was
designed and says everything runs on
Google infrastructure there are Google
engineers watching over these systems
day and night to make sure everything is
running smoothly so that you can focus
on your application in cloud language
App Engine is classified as a path
solution and this makes sense because
App Engine is a platform that takes care
of a lot of the complexity of building
scalable applications